dans cette banque alimentaire de l'est
de montréal les clients n'ont jamais été
aussi nombreux dès le début de la crise
la demande pour les services de
l'organisme a grimpé une augmentation de
environ 60 75 pour sa part parce que des
gens qui avaient jamais vu si tu es une
banque alimentaire de leur vie des
travailleurs des propriétaires dé foi de
duplex en septembre le groupe
d'entr'aide de mercier ouest a dû
s'adapter à la nouvelle réalité
il prépare des plats déjà cuisinés et
livre dorénavant des denrées aux gens
confiné ou qui préfèrent ne pas sortir
entre autres des aînés mais tout ça un
coup les dépenses ont remonté en flèche
de depuis le début de la crise d'août 19
pour aider les organismes à traverser la
crise le gouvernement fédéral a mis sur
pied un fonds de 350 millions de dollars
le financement sera redistribué aux
groupes communautaires notamment par la
croix rouge
on parle des petites org organisation
sans but lucratif sont incorporés un peu
partout dans les quartiers qui souvent
même pas eu des grandes campagnes arras
ont ils sont la situation ils doivent
augmenter leurs services mais il reçoit
pas de ça m'a plus de dons et récolter
des dons est plutôt difficile par les
temps qui courent
la société canadienne du cancer par
exemple n'a pas pu tenir la journée de
la jonquille et le bal de la jonquille
ce printemps
le relais pour la vie n'aura pas lieu
non plus ses 40% de son financement qui
vient de disparaître
la société canadian superstore prendre
une grande partie sa majorité de ses
revenus d'activités de collecte de fonds
qui sont des regroupements personnes
donc pour nous c'est plus de 80 millions
que nous allons perdre cette année parce
qu'on ne peut pas faire ces événements
l'organisme qui offre du soutien de
l'information aux personnes atteintes du
cancer sera fragilisée comment continuer
à donner un service aux gens avec une
perte de revenus comme ça c'est le
casse-tête auquel nous devons jouer
actuellement cet homme qui a été épaulé
par l'organisme alors qu'il souffrait du
cancer lance un appel à la générosité
prenez soin de faire un don aussi
minimes qui soit pour aider ces gens là
qui sont en besoin parce que comme je
dis malheureusement le cancer lui prend
pas de pause pendant le coït
ici olivier bachand réseau canada
montréal